[Musique]
et si l'argent était la solution
cette question peut vous surprendre va
peut-être même vous choquer si vous
savez que je suis un ancien banquier
suisse de surcroît si vous saviez le
bien que ça me fait vous le dire parce
que durant mes dernières activités dans
ce métier je portais ça comme quelque
chose de honteux tellement j'avais peur
qu'on voit deux mois l'étiquette plutôt
que l'être humain qui est derrière
alors qu'aujourd'hui je suis devenu un
peu par hasard un expert de la relation
à l'argent je vois à quel point toute
cette expérience m'est utile
ça m'a permis de voir à quel point les
êtres humains peuvent être irrationnel
dès qu'il s'agit d'argent
deux exemples comment est-ce qu'on peut
être millionnaire et avoir peur de
manquer tous les jours comment est-ce
qu'on peut s'entredéchirer pareillement
dans une famille lors d'une succession
alors qu'anna largement assez pour
chacun je ne juge pas parce que moi même
j'avais des revenus confortables et
j'étais plein peur j'étais stressé et
stressante mes proches alors je suis
particulièrement content d'être avec
vous ici en france parce que pour
intervenir dans différents pays je peux
vous dire la france et l'argent c'est
pas un mariage d'amour
quel crispation waouh c'est le seul pays
où j'entends régulièrement vivons
heureux vivons cachés il semble qu'ils
se vendent autant de rolls royce en
grande bretagne qu'en france bon je suis
pas sur cet exemple ça vous touche
personnellement un don qu'il s'en vend
autant la différence c'est qu'en
angleterre on roule avec en france en
lice dans le garage envoyée
si nous continuons à laisser autant de
place à l'art jour notre société à ce
qu'ils aient autant de décisions qui
soient prises uniquement pour des
questions financières à partir de peur à
partir des envies plutôt que d'écouter
son intuition plutôt d'écouter son coeur
je peux déjà vous le dire c'est no
fioutch 1 mais si vous êtes là je suis
vous avez envie de contribuer à cette
société en évolution
alors on va faire un premier pas pour
changer ça je vais proposer une
expérience vous allez adorer
en fait si je suis vraiment honnête et
vous-même ils n'arriveront pas aimé du
tout mais je pense qu'elle est utile
c'est pour ça je vous la propose alors
je vous invite à vous observer déjà là
maintenant au moment je vais commencer à
vous expliquer l'expérience et moment
vous allez à vivre ça peut être long
vous avez vous m par deux camps voisins
voisines si quelqu'un un seul par trois
ça ira aussi et vous aurez ça va durer
quinze secondes vous aurez un seul
chiffre à dire dans votre groupe
quel est le montant annuel de vos
revenus
savez vous allez adorer un ce n'est
qu'un chiffre je vous rappelle un psy
vous l'auriez oublié
alors pour ceux qui joueraient l'amnésie
qui se souviendrait plus je vous invite
peut-être à dire un chiffre approximatif
pas 35 entre 5020 à 1100 mhz il ya
quelques nuances quand même je vous
laisse 15 secondes
à vous de jouer
voilà les 15 secondes sont terminés si
vous le saviez comme je suis rassuré
j'avais peur que la moitié de la salle
déguerpissent à ce moment là merci
d'être toujours là alors j'ai envie
d'aller un peu plus loin pour vous
glisser au mot comprendre peut-être
l'essence de ce qui se passe dans ces
histoires d'argent et j'ai envie de vous
poser une question au moment où je dis
le mot argent s'il y avait un ou deux
mots que vous associez spontanément au
mot argent comme ça sans réfléchir
qu'est ce que ça serait bon je n'ai pas
le temps de vous questionner les 800
mais j'aimerais bien qu'ils entendent
3,4 réponse dans la salle qui me dire
comme ça ce qu'il vient alors si vous
tient quand même temps je comprends rien
quelques dépenses liberté riches
capitalistes voyage voilà dans le voyage
paisible
bon voilà on va remercier haut var var
étaient là parce qu'autrement on va y
passer le reste du temps vous savez j'ai
un temps limité et puissante le temps
c'est de l'argent et offre une part
exagérée alors j'ai posé ces questions
des centaines de fois je vous dire quels
sont les grands classiques sachant qu'il
y a pas de réponse juste une réponse
fausse j'entends souvent l'argent c'est
la sécurité
l'argent c'est la liberté l'argent c'est
l'indépendance l'autonomie
l'argent c'est la source de confort
l'argent c'est l'énergie l'argent c'est
la mesure de ma valeur et j'entends
aussi l'argent c'est sale
l'argent c'est l'injustice l'argence une
source de stress une source de tension
largeur une source de conflit l'argent
c'est la cause des problèmes dans le
monde
vous voyez c'est du 180 degrés
diamétralement opposées alors on peut se
poser la question c'est quoi l'argent
finalement si on y associe tous ces mots
là et celui qui était mon mentor kim
enseigne est le fruit de ses recherches
qu'il a fait plein des années sous ce
thème là peter könig disait l'argent
c'est comme un médium neutre où j'ai
comme un écran blanc sur lequel chacun
va y projeter ses propres images et
peut-être que j'aimerais vraiment y
avait une chose que j'aimerais vous
reteniez à l'issue de de ce passage
c'est que nos comportements avec
l'argent n'ont rien à voir avec l'argent
la source le moteur de nos comportements
de l'argent c'est nos projections sur
l'argent si je projette ma sécurité sur
l'argent je n'aurais pas du tout le même
comportement que l'argent que si je
projette que l'argent c'est une source
de conflit et pour vous montrer comment
ça se manifeste comme ça dans nos vies
ces projections je propose une
expérience dans l'enfer tous ensemble
devrait perdre vos deux mains et puis
une représente l'argent et l'autre
présente la projection on va dire la
sécurité que quand même très courante
alors vous allez prendre demain vous
allez mettre l'une les imbriquer l'une
dans l'autre et vous aller serrer un peu
les doigts serrés et un peu de tension
pas vous faire mal même un peu de
tension 1 et avant vous allez leur
demander de se desserrer vous même et
avant de le dire de le faire tandis que
je vous dise le mot de départ j'aimerais
vous rappeler une chose c'est que votre
voisin votre voisine
ils ont comme vous une oreille en et un
menton il aux médias qu'ils soient
intactes à l'issue d'expérience donc
tout en maintenant les doigts serrés
vous allez essayer des cartes et
maintenant il doit se serrer la côte
aussi d'écarter les doigts moi j'ai la
chance de personnes à côté je peux
mettre beaucoup de force et ça ne bouge
pas donc je garde la pression ça ne
bouge pas voyez ce qui se passe quand on
associe comme je lé fais dans des
dizaines d'années argent et sécurité
pour prendre cette projection là j'ai
créé un lien de dépendance sans lien de
dépendance qui est ma sécurité dépend du
montant de mes économies
donc j'ai couru après l'argent pourquoi
j'ai couru après l'argent pourquoi j'ai
projeté ma sécurité sous l'argent il ya
une seule et unique raison c'est parce
que intérieurement
j'étais insécure je manquais d'estimé de
moi je manquais de confiance en moi dans
ma capacité à faire face aux événements
de la vie je manquais d'amour pour moi
donc ce qui manque à l'intérieur
j'essaie de les chercher à l'extérieur
et je courais après l'argent en
économisant toujours un peu plus puis ça
ne marchait pas envoyer la ja l'argent
et la sécurité je faisais fausse route
je courais là alors que c'est de ça que
j'avais à m'occuper de ma sécurité
j'avais à construire c'est
ces fondations intérieure pour avoir
plus d'estimé de moi et je continuais de
courir large et fait fausse route
pendant si longtemps donc aussi
longtemps que j'ai pas compris ça et que
je me suis pas occupé de mon estime de
moi ça reste est comme ça et au fur et à
mesure que j'ai fait ce travail là mais
doit se sont détendus j'ai pu voir
qu'ils avaient l'argent d'un côté et qui
venait sécurité de l'autre c'était deux
choses complètement différentes
quelle que soit la projection positive
que nous avons sous l'argent c'est le
même principe qui se passe et jamais
vous puissiez repartir avec deux pistes
pour elle un peu plus loin et la
première je vous propose de voir pendant
les jours les semaines qui vont suivre
c'est essayer de vous observez comment
vous comporter dès qu'il s'agit d'argent
nous allons faire tous les jours à
l'argent en achetant votre repas de midi
en faisant des courses ce soit un moment
vous recevrez une facture ou payer une
facture où vous recevez de l'argent
ce moment vous discutez d'argent
peut-être avec quelqu'un de votre
capacité à vous faire plaisir à vous
faire des cadeaux à faire des cadeaux
aux autres comment vous comporter pour
essayer de mettre plus de conscience sur
votre fonctionnement et j'ai une
deuxième piste je me rends compte de
plus en plus que j'ai des êtres humains
il ya on est soit dans l'esprit de
manque ou dans l'esprit d'abondance moi
même j'étais dans l'esprit de mauguio
des dizaines d'années je voyais tout ce
qui n'allait pas de moi moi surtout à
quel point je n'ai jamais assez quelque
chose ait jamais assez bien mais
vis-à-vis des autres vis-à-vis de ma
situation vis-à-vis de mon compte en
banque etc
ça nous tire l'énergie en bas ce truc là
alors que ceux qui sont allergiques
d'abondance eux ils voient tout ce qui
est déjà là dans leur vie et sont
tendues merci sont à la gratitude même
voyez si les événements une vie et elles
mêmes ces deux vies complètement
différente et moi même aujourd'hui je
suis beaucoup plus dans la gratitude je
vois à quel point je suis parfois tirer
encore en arrière peu le côté du manque
pas ce réflexe tellement là pendant
tellement longtemps que je suis comme
conditionné par ça ça me demande la
vigilance pour revenir là et pour
terminer je me dire bien sûr je suis sûr
que vous comme moi nous avons tous vu
des situations où des gens parce qu'ils
ont beaucoup d'argent
ils vont profiter d'une manière ou d'une
autre
vont abuser de pouvoir ils vont
effectivement penser que tout leur est
dû parce qu'ils ont de l'argent que ce
soit de 20 compte dans une famille ce
soit dans le business ce soit en
politique ou autre nous avons tous des
exemples comme ça mais moi j'ai envie de
vous amener un autre regard sur l'argent
moi je trouve que l'argent est un
formidable de vote beaucoup plus
efficients que celui qui mettait une ou
deux fois par année dans une urne
pourquoi parce que chaque fois que nous
utilisons de l'argent nous donnons une
couleur à la société que nous
construisons
ainsi si vous allez acheter dans les
commerces locaux
vous leur donnez votre votre maudit vous
les encourager à continuer alors que
s'ils achetaient dans les grandes
surfaces mais vous encourager aussi à
continuer si vous achetez des produits
des services qui sont faits par des
entreprises que des valeurs qui sont
proches des vôtres vous les encourager
non seulement continuer à se déployer
parce que vous leur donnez à travers
l'argent leur donner une forme de
pouvoir de force de continuer et
al'inverse si on achète des produits des
services qui sont faits par les
entreprises qui n'ont pas du tout nos
valeurs nous les encourageons également
continuer de faire de la sorte et à se
comporter de la sorte c'est pas facile
hein je vous dis je compte beaucoup de
progrès à faire sa demande de s'informer
et ça va pas de soi on n'a pas tous les
informations si facilement que ça et
simplement
c'est important de se souvenir de ça du
pouvoir que nous avons moment nous
dépensons de l'argent
moi j'ai envie de vous inviter à gagner
de l'argent sans limite pas comme un but
en soi parce que là il y aura des
problèmes d'éthique mais comme une
conséquence d'un travail une activité
que nous faisons des passions avec
enthousiasme et dans lequel nous serons
peut-être dépassé par le succès que nous
aurons parce que tout cet argent là nous
serons le faire circuler d'une manière
qui a du sens d'une manière qui
contribue à une société qui soit pour 2
demain avec encore plus de force et
encore plus d'intensité et heureusement
il n'y a pas que l'argent qui permet ce
changement là il ya quelque chose
d'encore plus fort
que l'argent c'est l'amour l'amour qu'on
a pour soi l'amour qu'on a pour les
autres limbourg conapo la vie sacrée du
rapprochement
alors imaginez si nous arrivions à
utiliser notre argent avec amour avec le
coeur ça ferait une énorme différence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]